we've always heard about billionaires
who dropped out of college to launch
companies and hit it big everyone from
bill gates and mark zuckerberg to steve
jobs and michael dell in fact the
billionaires list is disproportionately
made up of college dropouts but while
these are insane success stories the one
similarity between all these stories is
that they happen in western countries
and more specifically america
not only does this make the journey
itself easier given that there's more
opportunity but more importantly the
consequences of failing are actually not
that bad
worst case scenario you can just flip
burgers at mcdonald's and live paycheck
to paycheck in many asian countries
however if you don't make it with your
business and you don't have a degree you
could very well end up homeless given
the extreme competition even for entry
level jobs despite this an indian man
named gautam adani was not only willing
to drop out of college but also willing
to drop out of high school to chase his
dreams
and just last week gautam surpassed
mukesh ambani to become asia's richest
person so here's how a high school
dropout became asia's richest man
taking a look back gautom was born on
june 24th 1962 in ahmedabad india his
father was a local textile merchant
which should have provided gotham with a
decent upbringing financially but the
problem was that gautam had seven
siblings so his father's average income
didn't stretch that far while his family
wasn't particularly rich his father's
small business likely swayed the core
values of the family generally in india
college is thought of as the holy grail
and people who don't follow the
traditional path are strongly
stigmatized within society but it looks
like gautam's father's business made the
family more open to alternative paths
and this was quite important given that
gautam hated school from the very
beginning he had very little interest in
academics and he didn't feel that skull
could get him to where he wanted to be
anyway so at age 16 he dropped out of
high school and moved to mumbai to give
business a shot he only had a few
hundred rupees in his pocket or less
than a hundred dollars it's not clear
what exactly he tried to do in mumbai
but it seems like it was a big failure
as gautam would return home and enroll
in gujarat university which is known for
having extremely generous admissions
they don't post a formal acceptance rate
so it's thought that anybody who applies
and meets the base criteria is accepted
in other words gautam basically enrolled
in a community college this didn't
matter much though as gautam would drop
out of here as well just two years later
at age 18. he traveled to mumbai once
again with a few hundred more rupees but
this time he had a plan gautam went
ahead and scored an entry-level job as a
diamond soldier at an exporting company
called mahindra brothers not to be
confused with mahindra motors while this
job didn't pay much it gave gautam
insight into the diamond business and he
would use this knowledge to start up a
diamond flipping business this turned
out to be quite successful and made
gautam a good amount of money it's not
like he could just retire but he no
longer had to worry about making ends
meet in the meantime one of his brothers
who was also inclined towards business
started up a small plastics factory and
asked out them to come join him given
that gautam didn't want to flip diamonds
for the rest of his life he took on the
offer but he never went all in on his
brother's business you see the plastics
industry was rather cut throat with
small profit margins and significant
competition so gautam didn't want to
build a plastics company but gautam did
quickly recognize a greater opportunity
within the industry one of the most
important materials required for plastic
production is pvc and it seemed to gout
them that all of their pvc suppliers
were faring much better than them so
gautam traveled to south korea to meet
with pvc producers and make an importing
deal and with that gautam launched adani
exports limited in 1988
gautam started the company with a total
of 500 000 rupees which at the time was
equivalent to about 36 000
initially the company imported pvc and
sold it to local plastic factories but
it didn't take long for gautam to expand
outside this beginning in 1991 the
indian government changed their attitude
on business and started passing
legislation that was much more favorable
to companies for example they lighten
licensing restrictions lower tariffs and
loosen banking policies this period has
since become known as the economic
liberalization of india all these
policies led to an influx of capital
into the indian economy and allowed
businesses to expand faster than ever
before which was perfect timing for
gautam gautam went ahead and leveraged
these policies to expand the company
into trading metals textiles and
agricultural commodities a few years
later india opened up the mandra
shipping port to private companies and
in 1995 gautam would win the contract
since then the mandra port has become
the largest private port in india gautam
quickly followed up the success by
opening up a power plant in 1996 and by
1998 the adani group became india's
largest net foreign exchange owner
despite all the success gautam was yet
to enter his most successful industry
which was the coal industry the coal
industry has historically had a high
barrier to entry given the massive cost
associated with starting up and the
monopolistic nature of the business
however on the flip side if you are able
to dethrone the current co-leader you'd
likely be said for decades gautam was
well aware of this so he didn't enter
this market until he was truly ready
which was until 1999. soon after gautam
formed a partnership with the leading
singaporean company called the wilmer
group together they launched a joint
venture called adani wilmer and this
cemented gautam's position within the
big leagues but when you start playing
in the big leagues you start dealing
with the big problems
one of the biggest concerns from many
billionaires is being assassinated and
or being held for ransom this is why
many ceos and billionaires spend
millions if not tens of millions every
year on security they also have many odd
practices to reduce the likelihood of
being assassinated donald trump for
example is one of the most flamboyant
billionaires out there you would think
that he loves fine dining and fancy
restaurants but more times than not
trump actually prefers to eat at fast
food restaurants he feels that if he
randomly shows up at a fast food
restaurant there's a much smaller
likelihood of getting poisoned than if
he made a reservation at a fancy
restaurant this is truly quite ironic
but it's part of the price you often
have to pay to get to the top it's not
clear how much gautam paid attention to
such threats but it quickly became clear
that he should have paid a lot more
attention in 1998 as gautam and one of
his friends santala patel exited the
karnavati group they were stopped at
gunpoint by a group of men
they forced the duo to board a van and
they took them to an undisclosed
location fortunately the group wasn't
looking to kill gautam they just wanted
his money and as soon as he handed over
two million dollars they were set free
the kidnapping was eventually linked to
two gangsters named fazel ulrechmann and
the bogelov darjee both of whom had
extensive criminal histories i'm sure
gautam was a lot more cautious following
this incident but 10 years later he
would find himself in yet another close
death encounter this time though it
wasn't on the streets of india it wasn't
one of the most luxurious and bougie
places in india the taj hotel on
november 26 2008 the taj hotel was one
of the targets of a series of terrorist
attacks a group of 10 terrorists invaded
the taj hotel killing dozens of people
and taking the rest of the hotel as
hostage unfortunately gautam was one of
the people at the taj hotel when this
attack took place and he says that he
witnessed death from a distance of 15
feet fortunately the hotel staff
heroically led the surviving victims of
the attack to the basement and
eventually a chamber hall where they
took refuge they stayed here for the
next two and a half days until india's
national security guards invaded the taj
and took out the terrorists on november
29 2008. evidently this was the worst
experience of gotham's life but it did
give him a new perspective on life which
he has carried with them ever since
so far we've covered the bright side of
gautam but many would argue that gautama
also has a dark side historically gautam
has been notorious for leveraging his
wealth and power to gain even more
wealth and power for example you guys
may be familiar with the prime minister
of india narendra modi recently he's
become one of the most influential
figures in international politics but
gautam has actually been supporting modi
since 2003 so there's no doubt that
gautam is within the good graces of modi
and many critics have suggested that
gautam has used this connection to
influence national politics and pass
beneficial legislation for himself aside
from strategic law being by far the
biggest criticism against gautam is his
environmental impact given that he made
a lot of his money from coal his
business is naturally going to have a
negative environmental impact but this
is not actually what critics are talking
about critics generally point to
instances in which gautama outrightly
defies environmental policies for
example in 2011 gautam's company
approved an unseaworthy ship carrying
coal for a voyage across the ocean the
ship ended up sinking which cost 60
thousand metric tons of coal to be
deposited into the ocean gautam never
did anything to clean up the mess and
simply paid a 975 000 fine similarly in
2010 his company caused a pollution
disaster in zambia that ended up
poisoning the kafu river and in 2016 his
company started work on their hazira
port without government approval which
made it impossible for local families to
fish on top of its negative
environmental impact many argue that
gautam is having a negative social
impact as well for example he's accused
of working with the police to intimidate
people off their land and he's accused
of exploiting workers many of his
low-level miners and construction
workers are paid less than four dollars
per day so clearly gautam is by no means
a saint but he is trying to turn the
tide
while gautam is by no means shutting
down his coal operations he has done
significant good deeds in other sectors
for example he opened free schools
across india which have provided
education to 100 000 underprivileged
children recently he has also been
trying to combat his negative
environmental impact last summer gotham
plus to invest 10 billion dollars into
green energy within the next three years
and that's just a fraction of his
commitment to invest 70 billion dollars
into green energy by 2030. this of
course doesn't negate all of his damage
from the past but it is nice to see that
gautam is being sensitive to his
environmental impact moving forward in
terms of wealth gautam reached a peak
net worth of 88.5 billion dollars when
he overtook mukesh ambani gautam has
since fallen back slightly below mukesh
but given that gautam is up 10 billion
dollars on the year and the mukesh is
down one billion dollars on the year it
looks like it's just a matter of time
until gautam decisively overtakes mukesh
but that's just what i think do you guys
think gautam got lucky or do you think
you can do it again today without a
college degree comment that down below
also drop a like if you think that
people without degree shouldn't be
stigmatized and consider checking out
our international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
ari and i'll see you guys on the next
one